how did Lei
Stanfield get famous I think I started
first recognizing that people understood
who I was on a sort of larger sense when
I played Snoop and Straight Out of
Compton get out really also was one in
Atlanta where I realized people started
just recognizing me from it so there was
this time where I was in the museum and
I was surveying some things in the
museum and I turned my head around and
there's this person standing right in
front of me surveying me um but they
kind of had like a dead pan face
look and I was like hi how are you and
they were like I was like okay and they
were like I'll let you go and then they
walked
off I was thankful for being released